初めは人を不快にさせない言葉使い出来る
から尊敬する暴言だえってぃこんにちは
はじめ社長と山田君ですやー
なんかいろいろ話すが効いてるんですけど
そうなんか直接きってないのと裏で豆腐
料理も逆に動画でと話してみたいなと思っ
てベンチは自分の気持ちとしてもなんか
直接痛いんでもそれはちょっと待ってい
けって言う何時間とかにはオッケーっと
いうわけでどうしますか
畑からの卒業っていうものを考えてました
うーん
a
さんが広がってはありました手書きでたし
1周敵が住んで多分実機とか持っている
考えていくんですよね作業卒業どういう
理由
俺が強いと思います a ね lost 高
となりする a
あっはいちょっと言われていえーいまぁ
一応色々
まあまあ
一番大きな理由としては
youtube のこと以外にもいろいろ
やってみたいなっていう気持ちがあって
て
自分
ちょ室の企業の人間じゃないんでで両立
っていうのはなかなか難しいなぁという
気持ちなんと初めに入って畑にで abr
ってなるとやっぱみんな二にもなっちゃう
し
源さんの方にも
かかる可能性があるかなという
彼の言うことを聞きたい
[音楽]
をですねいろいろ
youtube 以外でと通って言っても
ざっくりなっちゃう自分の中にはいろいろ
やりたいこと
今別々の
ある
他にそう
た十分でした芸た良ければ田中美海日書は
数号編集中とカミング活躍して見えちゃう
確かに右かちめっちゃうける
で土台は築かせていただきます
ガーそうなの
他に何か
色々あったん
いろいろできるプリペイド困難場面から
ないことはないんですけどなんでこの
タイミングで言い出したカッキーのまあ
自分中で大きなものがありまして一応なん
か色々違うこともやってみたいっていうの
はずっと考えたことなんですよ day
なぜこのタイミング切り出しかっていうと
自分で末に彼女に比べたっていうのが一つ
です
でやっぱ
失うものが何もなくなったので一回なんか
チャレンジしてみたいなというか俺が
youtube はじめたのと一緒だね
そういう形になります俺も教職教育学 b
たからさ正直こんなことって言ったらの
youtube で知ってるんだったけど
まっとうにやってれば安定して教職に就い
てね幸せな家庭を築いてって言うぜ設計が
あったけど俺も別れてからこういうことに
なっちゃってたから
そういうきっかけになる気持ちはわかる
一応
プラ2割がゲロめちゃくちゃダサいんです
けどやっぱ結婚とかその先のことも
いろいろ考えてやっぱ一人でやるんです
っていう店もあるじゃないですかんねだ
から工夫だしなかったんですけどなくあっ
たんで
やれることをやってみたいなって気持ち
だった
銀貨みたいなのねー
タイは違う気がする
竹田と
さてレースのやり
結構自分なりには上手く行ってると思っ
てるんですけどまた一さんの口からもなく
話し合いとか注射やみたいな言葉マって
なんかより
するようにはなってるんじゃないかと思っ
本当にいや不安ですけどねまあそうよね私
第一君が抜けたっていうのはもちろん戻っ
てきちゃってるけど最初みって言うといえ
ば出会いであっていいと思ってるから俺も
がいなくなるのは寂しいし
それ俺の意見だけじゃないことだと思う
畑のみんながどう思うかとかいろんな肝臓
とか色んな人の考えをくみ取って最終的に
はどうなるかっていうのは決めた方がいい
と思うんだけどお手としてはちゃんとさの
先にやりたいことがあるとか明確にこれ
やりたいんですっていうのがあるのであれ
ば俺は止めないかっ
[音楽]
1まずやりたいものがあってこれけっこう
なかなか厳しいものぽいんで
市は次行ってくっつけてとって順次指定
ちょ組んでくるっていうのは考えており
ませんでしたん
本当にまだぺちピールというのを入れ
フィールド講座本当にあるんですよ
これほとんどぶりな可能性の地にもう一回
あーなるほどねー
それをかっこいいわけちゃうなるほどね
それできたらすごい
ta 度でちょっとスゴイはずが高いに
やれることをやってみたいなっていうか
年齢的にはまだ間に合うとぽいんででも
それは遠い歩先本当卒業しようと思ったか
も動画のもつれの転送もカップどんな感じ
伊藤変わらずやっていますみんなも変わら
ずせしてくれてました葵
ちょっと違う楽にあった
そうですねなんかハ率ベストものが一応
言葉にしたことによってなんてうまく言え
ないんですけど
きも違うなぜかなかった
5が卒業した後もある
それ完全に消えたのはレンズ
二クラスその9裂孔
ほんとそれを聞くやんな結構でかい許家
[音楽]
月だっためちゃくちゃ付け歯
了解しました
もっと重い話かと思ったそれがいい意味で
前に進んでくれるんですけど逆に何か畑て
コースとてばよこれはちょっとぶつかった
生みたいでしょあっいやあ正直自分の
立ち回りもあまりうまくなかったのかな
っていう本当に畑へとしてバーンってきて
いるタイミングでもっと努力できる何かが
あったんじゃないかなっていう
自分の地力をつけるというかもう本当に
なったけど動画とって演習していっぱい
いっぱいになっちゃったんででももう
ちょっと頑張れる何かあったんじゃないか
なって言う
ことは求めましたね
ヤム
なんかも異色すぎるチャンネルが肇社長
あってできたものでたナッツとが大事かも
結局俺の友達と防衛だけどそこで明治では
ないから最初誰も明治期でしょ鉄にあって
来そう
正直言うと最初第一くって形良い強かった
しいや弾たって知らないんだ人が
怖いよ一さんはまだ動画見てるからあなた
人となりがねそそこんな感じで人だろう
なんだったんですよ3人マジで知らないし
ちゃうよ
それは全づらいなぁいいねm なぜかなっ
ん
ここで何かを言ってするってわけじゃない
けど俺はその
[音楽]
なんて思ったの方が気になったからそれを
聞いてみたっていうこと鼻血中も直接いて
良かった西する決定というか
物の到達はどうしたいかを一番最前線に
考えるけどいつもみんなで作っている
3ドルだから見たに向いている防衛
意外と思う
goo
一応畑から卒業するという形だったですね
もともと訓練が清水を持った行
戦う見終わってくれてたん
寿命を変えるんですかいやどうなんで
すげーベイトが必要がありなきゃわかん
ないよ協力やどうもー相性を染み付いてる
からな
こんなところに行ったほうがいい気がする
ななんでこのまま使わせてもらえるんだっ
たらとまた買っていきたいなと思います
ok でさ約カードはちょっといろいろ
また話し合ってみてくださいのみんなと
1本当に始めたに先に気持ち悪されたいな
ということでまだ本当になりもうちの
案内所というのはわずか雑魚かっていう
感じに卒業してしまったらまた話は変わる
けどトータルの気持ちはわかったからただ
この決める過程で気持ちが変わったりした
のでならいいと思うから
また考えてみてください
ちょっとれ叩きに残るにしてもとまたがら
せて
目標ができて
向かうんしても
応援したいと思っているのでれ視聴者の皆
さんも寂しいそんな昆布
地内でそんなことをやれとはいえらは彼が
決めたことであれば
応援してくれるととても僕も嬉しいと思っ
ておりますまだ全然パッチあったわけでは
ないから
夜考えてみてくださいなー
[音楽]
padi